[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it is
the bible
the word of god welcome to bible answers
live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor
would you like to hear an amazing fact
if completed the jeddah tower also known
as the kingdom tower
will be the world's first one kilometer
high building
3281 feet that'll also make it a
whopping
500 feet taller than the current record
holder
in the burj khalifa in dubai
construction began on the project
located 10 miles north of jeddah
in 2013. in fact the skyscraper
was going to be the centerpiece in the
first phase of a development known as
jetta economic city unfortunately in
the tower when it was about one-third
complete thousand feet tall
construction stopped because of problems
with workers
the builders said they planned to
restart construction in 2020
but then came the coven 19 pandemic
which is extended delays
so now for several years the silhouette
of a massive uncompleted tower
has dominated the skyline of this
arabian capital
you know the bible talks about another
massive tower construction project
that was interrupted by god stay with us
friends we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
welcome listening friends the bible
answers live and if you have a bible
question that's why we're here we invite
you to give us a call
the number to call in is 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297 with your bible
questions
we're also streaming this program on
facebook and that would be the doug
batchelor facebook page the amazing
facts facebook page
and it's on youtube and so give us a
call if you have any bible questions
anything related to the word of god
and questions about living the christian
life and we'll do our best to search the
word together and find the answers my
name is doug batchelor my name is john
ross good evening friends and you know
pasadena we always have folks who join
us on facebook so we'd like to greet
those who are joining us on facebook on
other social media i think we also live
on youtube also on your facebook
page as well as the amazing facts
facebook page so welcome we're glad that
you're part of our bible study program
this evening
let's start with the word of prayer dear
father we thank you once again that
we're able to open up your word and
study and we do ask that you'd be with
us be with those who are listening
wherever they might be lord if they're
driving in their car at home
we just pray that you'd guide us into a
clearer and a full understanding of your
word
and we ask this in jesus name amen amen
today you open the program talking about
well at least for now
plans for the largest tower in the world
and it seems like no sooner
are these towers built when some other
architectural firm and some other
builder decides to build one
a little bit higher it seems to be
ongoing
but this one was seemed to be well on
its way and then suddenly got
interrupted by
workers who had some complaints we don't
know exactly what that was
and then of course the pandemic and
they're hoping to get restart
restarted but you did mention a tower
that was interrupted also
well by god but it also resulted in
workers being confused
that's right you can find this in the
book of genesis chapter 11.
it says that after the people began to
scatter from the
ark you read in verse 3 it says the
people then said to one another
come let us make bricks and bake them
thoroughly and they had brick for stone
and they had asphalt for mortar
they said come let us build ourselves a
city and a tower
whose top is in the heavens let us make
a name for ourselves
lest we be scattered abroad across the
face of the whole earth
but the lord came down to see the city
in the tower which the sons of man had
built
and the lord said indeed the people are
one and they all have one language
and this is what they begin to do now
nothing that they propose will be
withheld from
them come let us go down there and
confuse their
language that they may not understand
one another's speech
so the lord scattered them abroad there
over the face
of the earth and they ceased building
the city
therefore the name of it is called babel
because the lord confused the language
of all the earth
and from there the lord scattered them
abroad over the face of the whole earth
so when i hear that story and you can
see pictures on the internet of this
unfinished tower there in the middle
east it
hearkens back to the story in the bible
where they had a city and a tower
project
and it came to a halt because god
basically
frustrated their language so they could
not understand each other's speech
and it makes you think about really how
that
curse all these different languages and
on problem communicating
that curse was reversed to some extent
when god
poured out the holy spirit in acts
chapter 2 and suddenly
the disciples were able to speak and
understand other languages they had
never
studied or known and
right now when people talk about
speaking in tongues in church
it seems like every church has a little
different understanding of what that
means
and you know we believe in everything in
the bible we believe in all the
spiritual gifts
but this gift of tongues is probably
more misunderstood than
many of the gifts of the spirit and
maybe some people have some questions
about what does it mean
to speak in tongues or to have the gift
of tongues
and what happened in acts chapter 2. we
have a book it's called
understanding tongues and we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks this is of course our free offer
this evening
we'll also be offering some other
resources but we want you to take
advantage of this opportunity it's the
book we'll send it to you in the mail
it's called
understanding tongues all you have to do
is call the number
800-835-6747
ask for that book it's called
understanding tongues we'll get in the
mail
as pastor doug mentioned it's an
important topic it seems like in the
last days the devil is going to do
everything he can to deceive and
well even misrepresenting the gifts of
the spirit is one of the tactics of the
devil so we want to understand what does
the bible say about this
again that number is 800-835-6747
we'll get that right out to you just
call and ask we got savannah who's
listening in canada savannah welcome to
the program
hi hi thank you for calling
yeah i was just wondering about like uh
being baptized for is it necessary to be
saved because
i have like two verses here that i'm
wondering about
well let's look at the verses okay so
there's one in
john 3 5 and it's talking about like
being
born of water in the spirit but i
thought uh being born of
the water meant like a natural birth
and then you need two births to be saved
like the
i mean two two different births he's
talking about like naturalness spiritual
um and then one in one corinthians 1
17 it says
christ did not send me to baptize but to
preach the gospel not with
wisdom and eloquence lest the cross of
christ
be emptied of its power so i'm just
wondering about those
all right well first of all let's look
at the first one there in john and
that's in the gospel of john chapter
3 verse 5 unless you are born of the
water in the spirit you cannot enter the
kingdom of heaven
is jesus talking about the physical
birth where a baby is you know in the
mother's
that amniotic sack of water is that
being born of the water
uh i don't think so because earlier in
the book of john he's talking about john
the baptist baptizing
born of the water is talking about when
a person makes a choice to come to
christ and we are baptized born of the
spirit is what god chooses and he does
and so we must have both baptisms the
children of israel when they came out of
egypt
paul says in first corinthians 10 he
says they were baptized in the red sea
the whole nation was kind of baptized
symbolically
and then they were baptized in the
spirit by this pillar of fire
that appeared and so they needed both
baptisms
the first thing that you see happening
in the gospels
is john the baptist the last thing jesus
says in the new testament is go ye
therefore teach all nations
baptizing them in the book of acts when
they repented and they came to christ
they said men and brethren what shall we
do acts chapter 2 and i forget the verse
30 something peter said repent and be
baptized every one of you
and you'll receive the gift of the holy
spirit so i do think that
jesus is saying you need both births you
need the birth that
john the baptist is offering but you
need a spirit birth
and christ then emphasizes what it means
to be born of the spirit to nicodemus
and so paul then in first corinthians
where he says god sent me not to baptize
he's talking about a situation where the
disciples were arguing about
who had baptized them some thought well
i was baptized by peter so i'm more holy
than you who were baptized by
apollos or baptized by paul and paul
said look my mission isn't to go and
baptize any of the elders could do that
the evangelists and deacons can do that
it says i'm mainly sent to write and to
teach
and he wasn't diminishing the importance
of baptism he's just saying that
my principle job is not baptizing
so baptism is very important it's as
important to a christian
as a wedding is to a marriage you know
we do have a book it's called baptism
is it really necessary it looks at these
verses and a number of others
and we'll be happy to send this to you
savannah the number to call is
800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for that book
it's called baptism is it really
necessary
if you're outside of north america you
can also read that book by simply going
to the amazing facts
website that is amazingfacts.com
thank you for your call we've got uh
let's see jeff is listening right here
in sacramento jeff welcome to bible
answers live
yes yeah you're on sorry i'm not from
sacramento so i was wondering where that
was coming from oh okay
well where are you from now i'm curious
i'm from montana
well that'll work that's kind of like
northern sacramento
but anyway your question
yeah so i have a troubling question
about um
advice on the bible and the sanctity of
life
uh and for someone with type 1 diabetes
that would choose to stop taking their
insulin
would that be considered suicide well
why would they choose to stop
stop taking insulin
because you're using some medicine to
stay alive
well insulin is required to stay alive
right i know but
it's not that hard to take insulin i
know some people that have been on
dialysis and it's very
exhausting very expensive and they've
done it for years and of course
sometimes they're very old and they said
look i just don't want to do the
dialysis anymore
and it was sort of like you know just
resigning themselves to dying but
taking insulin is not as intrusive on
your life
and i would think well if you know if
you had to take a pill once a day to
stay alive
stopping taking that pill is going to
kill you why would you want to do that
just so if a person wants to commit
suicide is that the real question
yes through that route yeah well that
would be
you know if a person knows that they can
take a pill
and stay alive and they can afford it
that would be kind of like saying i'm
going to take a pill that i know is
going to kill me and taking it
so it's making a choice you've got
freedom to choose to live
and they're choosing not to live that
would i believe
be like a choice to commit suicide if
you've got a medical treatment
available to prolong your life it's not
a difficult treatment
and you say no i think i'm just going to
use this illness as an excuse to die
why would you do that so it's really a
choice to
you know a person to end their life and
that would be in the same category
in my opinion is saying i'm going to
commit suicide it's not like being in
the hospital life support and
denying all the heroics to keep you
alive what are your thoughts
john i've never had this question yeah i
know that i i think you're right pastor
i mean it's hard to say
you don't know the motive if somebody is
choosing to do so in order to end their
life
like suicide but there are situations
where somebody might be
going through a whole barrage of
treatments maybe they have cancer
and they're going to have to go through
a whole lot of treatments to just add a
few more months or a year or so to their
life
at some point they realize you know it's
it's not worth it there's a little bit
that
little bit of time that i've left
quality is more important than quantity
and
in that case somebody might choose and
say you know i'm not going to go through
that
right that's different than suicide
though if they could they would live
but um somebody who is otherwise well
and they say you know i i want to
in my life and they they do so by not
taking some medication that's keeping
them alive
that could very well be a form of
suicide yeah so
i hope we're helping a little bit jeff
and uh i
i hope you you kind of asked the
question in the second person i hope
it's not you
and that uh you'll you're uh not
discouraged
um you know we have a book where just a
matter of fact i've completed the book
it's in the process of being printed
right now and it's on the subject of
suicide
it's called a christian perspective of
so um boy i wish i could offer that to
you now so you need to if it's you keep
taking your insulin until the book comes
out
all right thank you for your call jeff
we've got george listening from
washington george welcome to the program
george in washington kenosha washington
you there or wisconsin maybe wisconsin
sorry wisconsin wisconsin the font is
very small on our computers
yeah my my question is if god created
everything and everything was perfect
whether he created the earth knowing
that his son was gonna
die in a cross for us well
god makes all of his creatures free and
uh
you know god he even made a beautiful
angel named lucifer
knowing that at some point lucifer was
going to rebel and bring all this misery
and it just tells us how much god values
freedom in life
that he would do this and so he made a
world and he is going to fulfill his
final plan
ultimately this world god made though
there's been a battle
for you know regarding sin here in this
planet
this world is going to be filled with
saved people
it's going to be a beautiful paradise
the garden of eden will be restored
and god himself is going to live here so
god is going to accomplish
his final purpose for this world and
it's going to be a beautiful ending
and fulfillment of his original plan so
does that so basically
we're going to go back to a little bit
so basically we're going to
live like adam and eve back in the days
yeah it'll be better it's going to be an
upgrade
because of course jesus will be with us
and um
yeah there'll be no more sin or sorrow
or death and no more pain
you know the the broader question there
pastor is um
did god create a devil i mean he's the
one that brought all the suffering and
pain to the earth and
um why did god create an angel knowing
that this angel would eventually rebel
and um bring all this pain so god does
value
freedom and the freedom to choose you
know we have a study guide
called did god create the devil and it
deals with the subject a lot of people
wonder if god is good
why is there so much suffering and sin
in the world and the study guide will
help you understand at least give you
the bible reasons for why we have that
if you'd like to receive that the number
is 800-835-6747 and again you can ask
for the amazing facts study guide it's
called
did god create a devil and we'll send
that right out to you uh thanks for your
call
uh george we've got noah in rock falls
illinois
no welcome to the program thanks for
having me uh
gene and pastor doug yeah
so earlier this week i was having a
discussion
with my aunt on facebook
and she was stating like
my my main question is does the bible
say
if we'll be eating a plant-based diet in
heaven or not
is there any specific bible verses
because my aunt thinks
that we'll be eating meat in heaven and
i told her
whether you like it or not you've been
leaving plant-based
because in the garden of eden nothing
really died right well let's look at
that
and you uh pastor ross might look up the
original verses there in genesis where
it tells us what god's plan was for
man's diet
and as we mentioned with the previous
caller god is going to fulfill his
original plan
but you can also read speaking of the
new heaven and the new earth
in isaiah 65 it says they'll build
houses and inhabit them
they will plant vineyards and eat their
fruit
and so we're going to be you know eating
fruits grains nuts and things that grow
because
you read in revelation it says there is
no more death
so we're not going to be hunting down
cows and chickens and killing them
and grinding them up and eating them or
frying them and so yeah everybody there
is gonna
nothing will hurt or destroy it yeah
first other in heaven
we've got a verse in revelation chapter
22 verse 14. if you're writing these
down noah
here's one that i think is pretty clear
it says blessed are those who do his
commandments that they might have
right to the tree of life am i 18
through the gates of the city
the bible also tells us that the tree of
life will bear 12 different kinds of
fruit
so a different fruit every month it also
says that from
each month to another the redeemed will
enter into the new jerusalem into the
city
most likely to try a new fruit there's
12 different kinds of fruit a different
fruit for every month so yes
in heaven we will eat especially from
the tree of life
yeah and then you uh you can read where
it tells us
in the book of isaiah that the lion will
eat
a straw like the ox and the wolf and the
lamb will lay down together the animals
will not each
eat each other so certainly we're not
going to be killing and eating them
so i'm just getting used to the diet of
heaven now starting early yeah that's
good
all right thanks you call now we've got
uh daryl listening from phoenix arizona
daryl welcome to the program hello
thanks for taking my call
i was just wondering uh about
riding a city bus on the sabbath day
yeah that's a good question you know if
for those christians that
still believe in all 10 commandments
which includes keeping the sabbath holy
the bible says you should not do any
buying and selling
if you go to israel boy they're very
they're they're very fastidious about uh
the orthodox jews about keeping the
sabbath
and you'll see a lot of taxis are not on
the street and some buses don't run
and uh you and i were there was two or
three years ago now
and um there's even elevators that stop
on every floor so you don't have to
press the elevator button you just get
on and it will stop on every floor
because some thought well that's work
but you know i did meetings in new york
city
and we were meeting seven days a week
doing evangelistic programs and
we just got ourselves what they call a
bus card or something or
you know you buy your tokens in advance
and it you know i think
sometimes you do what you got to do to
get where you got to go and uh
the lord understands that so it's like
someone might say i can't use the phone
on sabbath because people at the phone
company have to work
whenever i use the phone or if i turn on
the lights there's someone as a power
company keeping the lights going
you can go crazy thinking like that so
and of course the bible tells us that we
should not
neglect the gathering of ourselves
together on the sabbath
to worship god so yes there is a command
that says gather together now of course
back in bible times
it was even a little more challenging at
times you'd have to bring the horse out
of the barn you'd have to hitch him up
to
to the wagon or the cart and you'd have
to go to church but that was necessary
in order to
fulfill the command that says don't
neglect gathering together
so i think there's a balance we've got
to take that into consideration that's
right
all right thank you for call we've got
um gavino
from san antonio san antonio davina
welcome to the program
good evening pastors can you hear me we
can okay
uh my question is when job offered uh
offerings for his children
in case they sinned is it safe to say
when satan
asked permission to attack job that it
was open season on them because
more likely they wouldn't protect it
under god and
more likely they'll be lost well i think
we've got to be careful not to assume
that someone dies in a tragedy that that
means that they're
they're lost sometimes a plane or boat
will go down
and uh they'll have you know hundreds of
thousands of people on it and that does
not mean that everybody that drowned or
died in some catastrophe was not a
christian
time and chance solomon says time and
chance happens to all even christians
have car accidents and die
and so the devil may have taken out
job's family but
job interceding for his children i think
there's a good chance that
many of them by his example and his
prayers will be in the kingdom
we don't know that but i don't think
because the devil
attacked his family that that means that
that well they must have been lost
yes god could have protected them and
a lot of good people die in war and that
doesn't mean that you know they're all
bad or why didn't god's angels protect
them but you know
in many cases there are promises that
the angel of the lord encamps round
about those that fear him and many times
god does miraculously intervene and
protect his people
but not always all right thanks for your
call we've got uh abigail listening from
l.a abigail welcome to the program l.a
or louisiana oh i'm not sure either way
hello hi abigail and your question
tonight
hello pastors um my question for tonight
is
why did god speak to people face to face
and biblical times did not speak to them
face to face today
now are you 11 years old oh
yes sir you're very articulate i'm
that's i'm impressed
but let me answer your question um
why did god speak speak to people face
to face well it is rare
and you know god may still choose to
speak to some people face to face before
the end
but the lord had special people that he
called
such as moses and abraham and jacob
and i think the angel of the lord spoke
to the parents of samson and a few
others in the bible
those are very rare occasions it's
entirely possible for jesus to still
speak to people today
because even after christ went to heaven
he spoke to the apostle paul
and so um i've read about some
missionaries and
and godly people through history that
say that the lord appeared to them and
spoke to him
and uh i don't doubt it that uh on rare
occasions he does that
it's usually he speaks through angels or
others or visions
or through a prophet often in the bible
yeah prophet would have a message from
god and relay it to the people good
question
thank you don't we have a lesson that
deals with prophets
yes we do i'm glad you reminded us
it's called does god inspire um psychics
and astrologists and we'll be happy to
send that to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 800-835-6747 that is the
resource phone line
and again you can ask for the amazing
facts study guide it's called does god
inspire astrologers
and psychics and we'll get that in the
mail to you if you
outside of north america you can just go
to the amazing facts website you'll be
able to read that there yep
we've got chris listening in florida
chris welcome to the program
chris in florida
sometimes they have the mute button on
and hear their name a couple times chris
you there
going once chris in florida go all right
twice
we might have to come back to chris
we've got jim listening in um
in indiana indiana there you go
from south africa we've got all the
abbreviations here i got to remember
what they are you know you only got 50
of them
all right jimmy here jimmy yeah
indiana yes you're on the air okay
um i was trying to
figure out how to explain to somebody
that the
communion service isn't literally
the body and blood of jesus christ
okay how would what scriptures would you
use
well right when the lord institutes the
last supper i think that it's very clear
when he said take this is my body and
take this cup drink it's my blood
they were symbols because obviously
jesus was sitting there with them
with his body and his blood still in his
body uh
you know he didn't have an iv running
from a vein into the cup
and so i think that they all understood
i mean even earlier in the bible he said
unless you eat my flesh and drink my
blood you have no life
so he was talking about you know taking
in his teaching
and his christ is compared to the word
of god and the bible says you know
that the word became flesh and dwelt
among us
jesus said man doesn't live by bread
alone by by
every word jesus said i am the bread
that came down from heaven
and so he's comparing himself to the
word of god
and his blood to the atonement for the
gospel
that we take by faith you know there's
some confusion i think jim
based on a verse that you find in john
chapter 6 verse 53
where people jesus speaks this most
assuredly i sent you unless you eat my
flesh and drink my blood you have no
life in you
well you read on a little further in
verse 60 the disciples were puzzled by
this and they said this is a hard
saying who can understand it obviously
they realize jesus wasn't talking
literally
and then jesus responded and you see
this here in verse
63 he says the spirit is the one who
gives life
the flesh prophets nothing then he says
the words i speak unto you they are
spirit they are life
so jesus explains himself by saying to
eat my flesh drink my blood is to
receive my word
and in that sense we feed upon the
living word of god
there are many parables that jesus gave
and we've got to allow the bible to
interpret itself
yeah this was a big struggle during the
reformation
some of the protestants one of the
reasons they broke away is because
in the catholic and the orthodox
churches they were teaching the priest
literally turns
the the bread and the grape juice into
the body and the blood of jesus but
jesus does not endorse cannibalism and
so they were
clearly symbols you hear the music
friends that just means
it's break time don't go away those on
the line will get your calls in just a
minute
and you can still call in the best half
is yet to come
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature
and much more call us at af bookstore to
learn more about it
at 1-800-538
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you
change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7290
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and if you have a bible
question you can still call in with your
question that number is 800
god says that's 800-463-7297
and i am doug batchelor my name is john
ross and we're going to go straight to
the phone lines we've got oscar listen
listening from new york mount vernon
oscar welcome to the program
yes thank you thank you very much i
i would like to understand something is
the
is healthy late on fire or is hell going
to be destroyed in the lake of fire
yeah okay well uh what we call hell
curse the word hell sometimes means
sheol or the grave in the bible but
typically when we say hell we're
thinking of
the place where the wicked are punished
for their sins
and it says there in revelation chapter
20 that
all that whose names are not found in
the book of life
were cast into the lake of fire is that
revelation 22 there's two passages that
talk about it
and um so it is the where they're
punished
each man according to his deeds it's not
a cavern down in the middle of the earth
somewhere
but it's hell is gonna burn on the earth
it says god
rains fire down from heaven upon them
and it devours them
the several verses actually pass it out
you've got revelation 19 20
talks about the beast that's cast into
the lake of fire
you've got revelation 21 verse 8 which
talks about the lake of fire which burns
with fire and brimstone which is the
second death
and then chapter 20 talks about the
devil who deceived them was cast into
the lake of fire so
several references to that but it's a
final judgment and final destruction on
the wicked
it describes in revelation 20 where the
wicked this is at the end of the 1000
years
where they mount this attack upon the
new jerusalem and it says fire came down
from god out of heaven and devoured them
that would also be
the lake of fire the final judgment that
comes upon the wicked
yep and we have a lesson that deals with
that if uh oscar would like a free copy
yes it's called is the devil in charge
of hell and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is 800-835-6747
again the study guide is called is the
devil in charge of hell
and we get this question quite a bit
pastor doug so amazing facts is putting
together a
very informative magazine on the subject
of hell and i believe it's uh in the
process right now
should be coming out in the next four or
five months so well we just want to let
our friends know about that
if you want more information just go to
the amazing facts website
and you'll learn about that yep thanks
for calling oscar we've got
christopher listening in texas
christopher welcome to the program
hello pastor can you hear me we do
how can we help you tonight so my
question today
uh i was wondering what is the trespass
money and what is the sin money
mentioned in the
in the book of second kings chapter 12
verse 16.
all right i kind of got an idea on
trespass money
uh but the send money especially i'm
like what what is sin money this is very
strange
um you know yeah is this some kind of a
old testament indulgence that you had to
pay
is that what you're wondering yeah i'm
wondering like what
what what is that well it's based on it
it's based on leviticus chapter 5 15.
let me read that for you
it says if a person commits a trespass
and sins unintentionally
in regard to the holy things of the lord
then he was to bring
to the lord as his trespass offering a
ram without blemish
from the flocks with your valuation in
shekels of silver in other words
they didn't have a ram they could bring
the value of it
in shekels according to the shekel of
the sanctuary as a trespass
offering and so uh they were basically
to
uh you know pay a uh the value of a
sacrifice
because you really don't pay for
forgiveness it's the land the blood that
was a symbol of what atoned for the sin
but some people traveling couldn't
always bring a ram or lamb with them
so they'd go and they'd either buy one
or they'd give it to someone else who
would be sacrificing
that's why they ended up doing all of
the money changing in the temple in the
days of christ
they were you know changing the money
and people were buying sacrifices and
jesus said it had turned into a flea
market and they chased them all out
you know there's also another reference
to the trespass offering that you read
about in numbers chapter 5 verse 6
and this one is in reference to somebody
who has wronged another person
and part of the the work was to make
restitution of that which was done
wrong and if he had wronged a person he
was to make things right
and actually add one-fifth of what he
had wronged the person
and that was also referred to as a
trespass offering so you've got the one
with reference to sacrifice or the
equivalent of the lamb or whatever the
sacrifice was
or if you have wronged another person
you were to make that right as well that
was also referred to as a trespass
offering
zacchaeus when jesus came to him and he
said lord if i've taken anything
from any man by false accusation i will
pay him for
fourfold i think he said yeah and so
there was you know a payment if you had
unlawfully taken advantage of somebody
and some of this went to the temple
so it was like a penalty you know if you
um if you speed
you pay a ticket well who gets the
ticket and goes to the county or
something
so all right thanks you call chris we've
got uh richard listening in new york
richard welcome to the program
hey how's it going pastor ralston pastor
doug uh quick question
um i've been uh studying a bunch of
stuff
uh relating to the final day and i i
can't
so anyway let me just get into it so
john
5 28 it says marvel not at this hour for
the hour is coming which all that are in
the grave shall hear his voice and then
referring to those that are of the
resurrection of damnation
along with the resurrection of life and
then 2 peter 3 10 says
but the the day of the lord will come as
a thief in the light in which
the heavens shall pass away with a great
noise and elements shall burn with the
fervent heat
so my question is when it refers to the
last
day because it says clearly there in
john 5
28 through 29 that all that in the gr
all that are in the grave shall hear his
voice so
i don't know like what's going on is so
when christ returns
is it really the final day where that
thousand years is a compass into one day
but on a biblical standpoint and a
spiritual standpoint it still stands for
for a thousand days because it says all
that is all that are in the grave shall
hear his voice
when he comes those that are a part of
the resurrection of the nation
those that are part of the resurrection
life tying it into
to peter 3 10 where it says when christ
returns all the elements burn with the
fervent heat so is the final day
truly the final day or is it drawn out
a thousand years yeah i think i
understand what you're saying well first
of all in john chapter five where he
said
all that are in the graves will hear his
voice he's talking about the
um the resurrection and there will be of
course the resurrection of the just
that's why he noticed he mentions the
resurrection of life
that's first then he says the
resurrection of condemnation
it always talks about the resurrection
of life first even in daniel 12 verse 1.
many it's dangerous it might be verse 2
of daniel 12.
those that are in the grave will hear
his voice they'd have done good the
resurrection of life
some to life and some to everlasting
condemnation
so and paul says the dead in christ rise
first and we know there's a
thousand-year separation
between the first and second
resurrection resurrections based upon
revelation chapter 20 where it says
blessed is
holy is he that has part in the first
resurrection on such the second death
has no power
the rest of the dead if the dead in
christ rise first the rest of the dead
or the wicked live not again until the
thousand years are finished that
thousand years though is a literal
thousand years
so when we think about the day of the
lord it's talking about when everyone's
destiny
is sealed when christ returns
that's you know the next thing that
happens then the righteous live and
reign with christ for a thousand years
in glory
at the end of that time period the dead
are raised so i don't think john is
lumping the two together he's saying
there's just going to be two
and the verse you refer to pastor
revelation chapter 20 verse six it says
blessed and holy is he who has part in
the first resurrection
on such the second eighth night has no
power then verse seven says now when the
thousand years were ended satan was
released from his prison
and he went out to deceive the nations
and then fire comes down and devours
them in verse 9.
so you've got a resurrection of the
righteous at the beginning of the
thousand years you've got the
resurrection of the wicked at the end of
the thousand years for the final
judgment
and then final destruction at the end of
that and we have a lesson on that we do
it's called a thousand years of peace
and we'll be happy to send that out to
anyone who calls and asks
the number again is
you can 800-835-6747 for the amazing
facts study guide it's called a thousand
years of peace or
again outside of north america just go
to the amazing facts
website you'll be able to read it there
as well next quarter that we have is uh
marty listening in michigan marty
welcome to the program
hi pastors thanks for taking my call
absolutely my question
pertains to the mark of the beast um i
believe it was last month there was a
magazine published
and a church leader said in there that
the mark of the beast was
any day other than the sabbath day
could you clarify that for me please
well i can't comment on you know what
someone said in an article but i can
tell you what the bible says
is that the mark of the beast first of
all
let's let's talk about the seal of god
because you've got two opposite marks in
the bible
the seal of god first and foremost is
having the holy spirit
and but then there's also something
tangible it says
bind up the testimony seal the law among
my disciples so
having the law in the heart is going to
be fulfilled
when you are filled with the holy spirit
but then in the law of god
you've got one commandment where you
find the word holy
and it's the longest of the ten
commandments in the middle of the ten
commandments it's the only commandment
that begins with the word remember
and we believe there's going to be a
revival of people who to
return to the god of the bible and
they're going to be keeping the sabbath
and so you know you love god you give
them your time
anyway so that that is connected with
the seal of god
you've got the name of god in that
commandment you've got his title and his
territory
and that's what's in the seal those
three things the name the title the
territory of the monarch
then you've got the antithesis of that
which is the mark of the beast
it's going to be a counterfeit and it's
going to be i believe
a day that's going to be kept by uh
the apostate movement that's an opposed
opposed to god's truth and we've got a
lesson that'll talk about that and we
will send you a free copy
if you'd like to learn more about the
mark of the beast because you read about
this in revelation chapter 13
if you want to know what the mark is you
first need to figure out what the beast
power is that's spoken of there
i will send you a study guide that gets
into all of this it's called the mark of
the beast
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks incidentally
that's part of three angels messages
where it says don't worship the beast
don't receive his mark
so it's an important subject
incidentally a beast represents a
power a religious political power in the
last days
so we'll be happy to send that to you
the number call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called the mark of the beast we'll get
in the mail
and get it right out to you thanks for
your call marty we got angel listening
from
oregon angel welcome to the program hi
pastors uh thank you for having me in
the program um yeah
can you can you tell me well we do all
right so my question is um
which state was did jesus really die was
it a friday
because um i have like friends like
someone was telling me that like
we're out there two days and three
nights and that he is that actually on a
wednesday
yes thursday with a ceremonial sabbath
and then
friday again with preparation and then
you get resurrected on the saturday so
yeah i was kind of confused about that
yeah
i've heard that no jesus died on friday
the reason that
some people bend over backwards and go
through all these biblical gymnastics to
try to get jesus dying
on another day and it's because of one
verse in the bible
they read in matthew chapter 12
where jesus is talking about the sign of
jonah and jesus says for
as jonah was three days and three nights
in the belly of the
fish so the son of man will be three
days and three nights in the heart of
the earth
they automatically assume in the heart
of the earth means well the grave
but that's not what jesus is talking
about christ is talking about
that he was going to be in the clutches
of the devil
in basically a captive of the devil
suffering for the sins of the world
three days and three nights
that began thursday night so you've got
thursday night
friday night saturday night christ's
sufferings began
after the last supper when he was
in the garden he prayed three times not
my will thy will be done then he told
the disciples
now is the hour he said to them when
they woke up
now is the hour this is the hour for
which he came into the world
all up until that time he used to tell
everybody not mine
hour has not yet come but his hour to
suffer for our sins began
that thursday evening the mob carried
him off god no longer protected him
god withdrew his presence and protection
jesus was
tortured he was beaten he was mistreated
he was mocked
that his sufferings and his death took
place from
thursday night friday night saturday
night
he rose sunday morning so if you look
through
if you keep that perspective in mind you
still have three days and three nights
you don't have to try to create a
wednesday crucifixion i've got some
friends that
are hung up on that and they try to make
it but
we also know the bible says that uh the
sabbath when
jesus died was what they call a high
sabbath because the passover fell
on the weekly sabbath and they used to
claim a double blessing
so and it tells us clearly that the
preparation day drew
on that's always a friday for the jews
and of course
jesus said of the devil that he was the
prince of this earth
and so he's in the heart of the earth
meaning thursday evening yeah
it was as if the devil had a special
avenue to try and persecute christ
yeah and he went through that agony
thank you for your call angel we've got
uh
by the way but angel we do have a book
on that it talks about it it's called
the sign of jonah yeah if you want to
call that up there and i was gonna
forgot to mention that we'll be happy to
send it to you it's called the sign of
joan and the number is 800-835-6747
and we'll send you the book called the
sign of jonah cindy's listening from
arizona cindy welcome to the program
hi pastors um hi i'm calling about uh
the gospels talk about the resurrection
of lazarus and the resurrection of
jesus and when i compare the two i
notice
that with lazarus jesus says unbind him
and let him go
but when he resurrected and um
no one's there to unbind them well well
we know that
but well we don't know that actually do
we i mean do we know that
well who knows but anyway um my point is
that
he says to the women you know mary
magdalene and i
believe the mother um you know don't
touch me
so he's saying for lazarus you know put
your hands on him and unbind him but
then
in his case he's saying don't touch me
and then also
in addition to that i just wanted to
know your thoughts on on why the
differences between the two
and in addition uh
jesus actually folds the cloth
and sets them you know inside the tomb
and there's some significance to folding
very good folding linens you know
and in my opinion i i'm thinking i i
don't know if i just
because i'm i'm kind of a seamstress in
a part-time
but anyway um there's there's there's uh
there's a real thing if you go to a
restaurant you know you fold the napkins
or
you know that means that you're you're
returning when you just
toss them aside it's like i was
discussing right what i just ate
but anyway let me jump in yeah um
first of all when we talk about was
there anyone to help unwrap
him when he rose we know there were two
angels there
one one version says there was a an
angel but
the women who came later actually saw
two angels
so i think angels were there to help
unbind him
i think that jesus did fold the napkin
because that's an evidence to john when
john
saw the grave clothes folded or at least
part of it folded
he thought well if the body was stolen
they wouldn't have done that but i know
jesus
jesus is neat and meticulous and that
i john knew that he was really alive
when he saw the folded grave clothes
and when it says that mary uh he said to
mary do not touch me
that's in the king james it's not the
best translation there
the word really is do not cling to me
he was getting ready to ascend to heaven
he says now do not cling to me she
wanted to fall at his feet and grab him
and worship him he said i have not yet
ascended to my father
so there was no problem with her
touching him he just said don't detain
me because i must ascend to the father
and
because when he comes back that evening
he tells them all
hail and they fall down they worship him
he says touch me
you know i'm not a spirit i'm real so i
think that
that's what he was saying to mary at
that point but good questions you know i
do have a book i've written
and it's not one we can give away
because it's sort of in a different
category but it's a book on mary
magdalene and it goes through everything
i just described in more detail
and it's called at jesus feet and i
think you can find that on amazon or
amazing facts bookstore okay and the
next caller that we have is
michael listening in wisconsin michael
welcome to the program
wow okay i didn't expect to be on so
soon
well we're glad to have you here i got
my speaker phone up where did it go
turn off okay
some people say the world will be in
total chaos before jesus returns
but matthew will both record for us
jesus words
as it was in the days of noah it will
also
be in the days of the son of man people
will be eating drinking mirroring and
then they'll enter the ark
and the flood came yep so which is it
well yeah that's interesting you would
ask that because i was actually uh
sharing that in my message this week
those very verses and explaining that
christ said in such an hour as you think
not the son of man comes as it was in
the days of noah as it was in the days
of lot
life was they were all embroiled in life
they were buying and selling and
marrying and building and farming
and he said then suddenly the end
overtook them and he said that's how
it's going to be at the end of the world
at least up until the close of probation
it's going to seem like you know up
until the plagues begin to fall it's
going to seem like life is normal but
once probation closes
no one else is going to be saved and i
think things are going to just
unravel at that point something like
when moses came to pharaoh and said let
my people go they were
building and planting in egypt and doing
all those normal things
and but once the plagues began to fall
everything went wild
and that's i don't know your thoughts
are pastor ross but that's how i
reconcile those two as i i
think up until the end them those people
still going to be
doing commerce and all kinds of things
until the plagues fall
and there's that window of total part of
the signs of real close to the second
coming of christ not only is there
natural um events happening in nature
there's
floods and famines and fires there's
economic collapse
so the business is going to be a little
different it's going to be affected so
but that happens like you say after
probation closes up until that point
life seems to go as normal we do have a
study guide it's called
ultimate deliverance it's all about the
second coming and i'll give you a number
of verses connected with that
and i think you'll enjoy reading that
michael the number to call is
800-835-6747
that's available to anyone who would
call and ask
uh next quarter that we have let's see
we've got uh peter
listening in arizona peter welcome to
the program
thank you uh gentlemen
i have uh i've always been confused
about forgiveness of sin
and what it is is i was told that if
let's say i was a a thief
or i was a drunkard and
i asked god to give me those sins and
then i change my ways so that i don't do
these things anymore
now it talks about at the time of the
end
the books are going to be opened now
are the righteous also are there sins in
in
in the books for uh to be read
or is it only the um the condemned
that are gonna have their sins read and
uh it's gonna become known to all
what this was well when we come to
christ
and we lay our lives down and we take up
our cross and we follow him
we accept the blood of jesus to cover
our sin
at that point all of our sins our record
is plunged into the
depths of the sea it tells us in the
book of micah
and god he forgives us the ones who are
judged
are the ones who have not had their sins
forgiven and they are not under the
blood
and so that's all the more reason for
everybody to accept jesus because those
things
done in secret will be shouted from the
mountaintops
and we all want our sins
covered by the blood so the righteous
are not judged for their sins
they're judged for the righteousness of
jesus i should yeah the saved
basically get credit for the
righteousness of jesus so the books open
it's going to say forgiven
you know we have a verse that brings
comfort to those who are christians acts
chapter 3 verse 19
it says repent therefore and be
converted that your sins may be blotted
out
at the times of the refreshment come so
and then revelation chapter 3 verse 5
says if you don't repent your name will
be blotted out of the book of life
so either your name gets blotted out
which means you're lost or your sins get
blotted out which means you're saved
yeah good point and it's the lord has a
big eraser but you
you must accept jesus and repent of your
sins
well thank you appreciate that and do we
have a question we got philip from
florida phillip we have just a few
moments left and you're on the air
um yeah so my question is is that um
when this current earth is destroyed by
fire
and then we're all living in the new
earth well is it true that
we're all going to have um brand new
names
so what i'm saying is that my name won't
be philip anymore
we're all living in a new earth i'll
have a brand new name
is that true you know there is a passage
in revelation i think pastor ross is
looking it up
it says revelation chapter 3 verse 12 it
says to him overcomes i will make him a
pillar in the temple of my god
and it says i will write on him the name
of my god the new jerusalem
and i will write upon him my new name
and
verse 7 chapter 2 verse 17 was the one
i'm looking for
it says we receive to him overcomes
receives the stone
with a new name written on it which
nobody knows except the one who receives
it
yeah it's not that there's anything
wrong with the name philip
uh but you know in it's like we've got
our old reputations here in this life
connected with our names and we've all
sinned basically god is saying
we enter eternity with a fresh pure
reputation
and so people will find you and they'll
know your new name
and you won't have to worry about that
but i think the lord gives us all a
fresh beginning in the new earth
thank you everybody for your calls
tonight you know it won't be fair if we
take someone else and just
um maybe we'd have to cut you off before
you get to finish your question
we will take the last few moments to
remind you a couple of things one
this is a totally self-supporting
ministry
we're not underwritten by any
corporations or denominations or
organizations it's just folks like you
listening that say i'm blessed by this
program and they send a little something
to keep us on the air it's so easy to
give just go to the amazing facts
website
and we've got a special event coming for
youth pastor ross
starting on the uh next month actually
it's starting on the 19th of may it's
called
undaunted courage it's a special youth
program it's going to be broadcast on
social media also on youtube as well as
on af tv and we want to encourage
especially young people to
take a look at that it's all on the
website the amazing facts website and it
will be a great blessing so it's like
15 to 20. tune into undaunted courage
all right god bless you listening
friends and
don't forget you can find out so much
more about this program at
amazingfacts.org
we'll study god's word together again
next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country
come together to reveal the hidden
history of the book of revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects
this 95-minute masterpiece brings to
life the book of revelation
like never before revelation is no
longer a mystery
get your copy today visit itunes or
afbookstore.com
journey back through time to the center
of the universe
discover how a perfect angel transformed
into satan the archvillain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet
and the first humans witness the
temptation and evil
discover god's amazing plan to save his
children
this is a story that involves every life
on earth
every life
the cosmic conflict if god is good
if god is all-powerful if god is love
then what went wrong
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at af afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org
did you enjoy this program make sure to
tell your family and friends
tune in next time for more bible answers
live
honest and accurate answers to your
bible questions